back at it with a doctor react series
this week I'm tackling scrubs this show
is supposed to be a comedy but I've also
heard that it's rated one of the most
medically accurate shows out there let's
find out
line number one doctors don't wake up at
6 a.m. we wake up at 4 a.m. or 5 a.m. at
the latest because usually we have
patients scheduled for 6 a.m. or if
we're gonna be on a hospital ship you
need to come in for rounding and
pre-rounding I don't know what kind of
doctor this guy is but 6 a.m. is a bit
late and 3 years of pre-med 4 years of
med school and tons of unpaid loans that
made me realize one thing good could you
go drop an NG tube on the patient in 234
and call the attending at the lavage is
positive I don't know jack your first
day in the hospital is a scary day and
I'm not talking about when you're a
medical student on your clinical
rotations because no one really expects
much from you and you're a medical
student when you go in as a resident
your doctor you have a medical degree so
people have expectations that you'll
know what you're doing now just because
you have the knowledge from a textbook
on how to accomplish something it
doesn't mean that you have first-hand
experience and hands-on experience
really matters especially when dealing
with other people because medicine is
about dealing with people not disease
hospital doesn't want to be sued being
sued is not a good thing finally doctors
if there is a mistake don't admit it to
the patient here's a fun fact about this
common sense wise you may think that yes
if you hide the fact that you made a
mistake you're less likely to get sued
but what research has actually shown is
that if you're honest and come clean
about your mistake which doctors totally
make mistakes we're not robots if you
come clean about your mistakes and show
the proactive steps you've taken to
prevent that mistake from occurring
again patients are less likely to sue
you patients families are less likely to
sue you so it's about owning up it's
about being a good person and if you're
a human first you're less likely to get
sued I'm a tool I'm a tool I'm a tool
tool tool and unbelievably annoying tool
yeah
yeah finally these are your beepers from
now on they control your entire life you
would actually think that because it's
2018 or at least when I was doing
residency was 2017 you wouldn't have
beepers anymore guess what we still have
those same pagers it's crazy I actually
had the communications people from the
hospital send a message to my phone
instead of to the pager and actually
hasn't changed that to me just felt way
too old-school to be walking around with
one of those pagers on me you've done
this to cadavers before so this guy's
alive just poke it through a skin poke
it through now times up Carla would you
do it for him please I'm also gonna need
an ABG okay this is actually really
funny very true that when you go in your
first day some of the senior doctors
will want to see your ability to do some
of the procedures like put an IV in to
do an ABG which is an arterial blood gas
it's basically when you go into the
artery usually the radial artery which
is at the end of your wrist it's one of
the harder sticks because you can see
veins the artery you actually have to
feel the pulse and then insert the
needle based on where you're feeling the
pulse dr. Dorian can you tell me what
ailment Motz all I think I'm gonna love
rounds it's like being on a game show
what is uremia that's my boy this is a
cool example of what rounds are you
basically have a list of patients that
your team is responsible for and you go
around with your entire team with the
attending being in charge sometimes it's
the chief of Medicine and you walk
around to each patient's bedside and you
discuss the case not only with the
patient but with the team as well
sometimes you get the doctor asking you
questions that's a form of pimping
they're trying to get you to think
outside the box the way that I like to
lead rounds is sometimes we know already
what the patient has because it's
written on our reports but I would say
well what if this test came back
negative or what if mr. Johnson
presented without the headaches what
would change in your diagnosis and that
way can facilitate how a person thinks
because the quality of a good doctor is
being able to adapt is to be able to
think on the spot back in the day they
were very mean about this pimping
process and if you didn't get it right
they would talk down to you they would
call you stupid I don't see that
negativity there anymore and I think the
whole process has become a lot more
positive reinforcement based I'm going
for it
infection that's my girl
moving on I know I'm sure you did good
you know good but thanks if there's
anything I can ever do for you just you
could let me take you to dinner tomorrow
night we're back to the sex even a
comedy medical show that is funny on its
own still needs to have a little sex
thrown in there what the hell are you
doing all those newspapers are very
legitimate like having a ton of
newspapers just sprawled about that are
very old having that horrible TV that's
like sitting way to high up so you have
to Jack your neck up you daydream a lot
especially when you've been up for 24
hours so that part of this is very
realistic did you actually just page me
to find out how much tylenol to give to
mrs. lens nur could exacerbate the
patients it's regular strength tylenol
here's what you do get her to open her
mouth take a handful and throw it at her
whatever sticks that's the correct
dosage I'm gonna be honest and say that
I've done stuff like this my first
rotation going into residency was on the
surgical unit and I texted my senior
residents or attendings for everything
and then after a few weeks I realize
like why am I doing this if I know it's
the answer and I've double-checked that
it's the answer why am I asking for
permission when I have a Doctorate
degree so it takes some time to build up
confidence not every person works at the
same pace so I totally get whatever he's
coming from asking about the tylenol for
the love of God what about her she's
dead oh my god this shows crazy if they
find out the nurses are doing your
procedures for you your ass will be
kicked out of here so quick it'll make
your head spin
nurses do the majority of the procedures
as it is now if the procedure is too
difficult you're the one that's
responsible to come in and solve that
problem if then you can't do it and you
can escalate to either another resident
or maybe the attending physician but
generally nurses are better at doing the
procedures than us because they do them
so much more often so their hands are
much more well equipped to do the
procedures
really dance this is such a wicked
shouts oh and like that I was back in
high school
you see Surgical interns they're all
slicing and dicing at the jocks medical
interns we're trained to think about the
body diagnose test the medical interns
well you got a state where the Chess
Club ah not exactly accurate but has
some truth behind it Surgical interns
and residents are much more practical
they see a problem they want to fix it
they want to go in and cut reassemble
suture whereas as a medical intern or
resident you have to really think about
is this patient gonna follow the
treatment is this medicine gonna
interact with all these other
medications sometimes surgery will
consult us as the medical team to come
in and manage something that's very
simple for us but to them it's something
that they don't do often whereas on the
other hand we'll call for their help on
simple surgical procedures even like
sutures if they get too complicated for
us it's really about teamwork and making
it a balanced approach my first coat see
here's how it works
someone's heart fails they beat everyone
the first doctor in has to run the room
tell everyone what to do basically
decide if the patient lives or dies
what am I crazy in general you have a co
team that's said to respond to these
code blues yes it's about who gets there
first but it's not about any doctor in
the hospital she'd just run up and start
treating the patient we have teams
dedicated for this because imagine if
everyone's busy and no one responds what
the person just ends up dying not the
case there's strict responsibilities
here in my hospital the way it worked
was the ICU on-call teams usually ran
the code and if there was something else
going on then the medical team came in
and ran the code not gonna lie it was
scary when you would have one code and
then another code hype happened
simultaneously and then maybe a rapid
response meaning that someone's heart
didn't stop but something serious was
happening where their heart may stop
soon and at the same time you get an
admission it can get really hectic
[Music]
jammer
wears night on call start soon huh yeah
she must be excited oh you betcha the
first night I was on call I was
terrified because you have one senior
attending and if they get busy with
something it's all on you and you're so
worried about making the wrong decision
but if you double-check everything that
you do speak to people who have more
experience than you when you aren't sure
about what to do you're gonna be fine
while those nerves are totally normal
and expected there are ways to combat it
by being informed by being knowledgeable
and by being smart
I can relate to the feeling of like
coming on call and instantly getting
things to do for me my call started at
7:00 p.m. so when I would go in at 7:00
p.m. the team that's coming off would
hand off to the pages to me and say hey
we were so behind that there's still
three or four admissions that are in the
emergency room that needs to be done and
brought into the hospital so you come in
and you already have stuff to do and
then on top of that you're getting pages
about new things that are going on the
attending things it was a pulmonary
embolism no way anyone could have caught
it anyhow you have to pronounce it why
didn't anybody page me okay so this is
an interesting thing pronouncing someone
dead is usually done by the on-call
resident so that's accurate what happens
is if a person dies in the hospital the
nurse pages the on-call resident they
have to do a full exam we look at the
pupillary response pain threshold we put
a pen on the nail bed and we press very
heavily so the patient is somehow not
dead they would wake up we listen to the
horror we listen to the longest for
extended period of time there's like
this whole physical exam don't we do and
then we write it a long note calling the
time of death suspected cause of death
in addition to that once you pronounced
the patient you have to talk to the
family which is a very difficult
conversation you mature very quickly
during these moments even now when I
finally get to go home and the back of
my head on all the hospitals still here
wide awake that line is very true
there's been times like I was in a good
mood to go home and I was like let me
just roll through the ER and something
happened and I needed to help someone
out and I ended up staying three four or
five hours past my shift it's like one
of those things go home while you still
can cuz you need to be back here the
next night to save lives the most
important thing is that I got through my
first three days without looking like a
complete idiot
another episode of the doctor react
series is in the books mixed feelings on
this one and that's surprising because I
thought I would find it really funny
there was definitely parts that had me
laughing and I was like yeah that's so
true I don't know some parts are just so
dark and mean-spirited that I couldn't
get behind it it pushes a lot of the
stereotypes on the medical community
that aren't good to be pushed and we
should be getting rid of them instead of
celebrating them I probably need to
watch more episodes to truly understand
what the characters are all about if you
like this type of content please
subscribe down below cuz it tells
YouTube that you really enjoy this
content and it allows me to continue
making this type of content and if you
have a show that you love or specific
episodes of the scrub series that you
want me to watch leave it down below in
the comments as you know I react to the
comments all the time if not in the
comments section in my monthly
responding to comments video as always
stay happy and healthy
[Music]